Russia has signed a deal to station
tactical nuclear weapons in Belarus
defense minister Sergey shoigu says the
decision was taken after what he called
a sharp escalation on Russia's borders
yes
the Republic of Belarus was and remains
our true Ally and a reliable partner
Today We Stand Together against the
collective West which leads an
undeclared war against our countries
let's speak to journalists at Yulia
chapovalova in Moscow so how does the
Russian side explain the deployment of
tactical nuclear weapons into Belarus
so defense minister shoigu said the
decision to deploy Russia's
non-strategic nuclear weapons onto the
territory of Belarus has been dictated
by the activity of NATO's nuclear
missions so Russia and Belarus had to
take retaliatory measures according to
the minister the two countries have
begun have begun implementation of the
things the belarussian side has already
received the iskande
um missile system capable of using both
conventional and nuclear weapons some
Belarusian aircraft have already been
modified to use the nuclear weapons and
Bill of Russian servicemen I have
undergone special training at the same
time Russia will not give control over
its nuclear weapons to Belarus and
Moscow not Minsk will will make
decisions regarding the use of the
weapons the deployment decision was
first announced by president of Vladimir
Putin back in March
Russia also not happy with an
investigation into the Nordstrom
pipeline attack tell us more about that
uh the Russian foreign Ministry
expressed its protest about the complete
absence of results in the investigation
that's according to them of course uh
presumably carried out carried out by
the authorities of all of those
countries we're talking about Germany
Denmark and Sweden uh and uh we
obviously talk about the investigation
regarding the sabotage at the Nordstrom
gas pipelines in September 2022 the
foreign Ministry also noted the
inability of those countries to ensure
the transparency of the investigative
actions Russia demanded to conduct an
open investigation with the
participation of Representatives of the
Russian authorities and the authorities
of gas prom but those demands and no's
have been ignored Russia also claimed
those countries blamed rather those
countries for trying to hide true
perpetrators of the crime and at the
same time the Russian foreign Ministry
expressed
hope to continue to influence the
authorities of Germany Denmark and
Sweden to make them conduct an objective
and transparent investigation of the
sabotage on the North stream 1 and
Nordstrom to gas pipeline with the
participation and involvement of Russia
of course
Julia thanks for that uh you let
yourself reporting from Moscow